je vais lui dire eric et ramzy merci ben
voilà oui mais c'est vrai je suis pas
sage ivotel 21 avril
j'ai barré la route à chirac également
ça va on a une avant-première à lodja et
ça fait un peu de route
merci aux développeurs d'avoir été avec
nous le vîmes j'appelle double zéro et
unissons nous appelons le siège avec
edouard baer
voir
vous savez
koné jamais vous ne reverrez pendant qq
mais pour qui il se prend la mer de la
vie de merde là avant toi dans ton cul
c'est qu'à la fin on trouvait ça va je
suis français c'est tout à l'heure plus
de récupérer ma carte choisie car je
remercie j'étais venu pour ça et
maintenant elle l ina